China's quiet stance on Ukraine and
pressure on Taiwan poses serious
security threat according to Japan
officials say the Japanese are
undertaking their biggest arms build up
since the second world war to deter
Beijing
there are also reports out today that
the United States is considering
producing weapons with Taiwan either
providing the tech for production in
Taiwan or using Taiwanese parts to make
the weapons in the U.S
the Taiwanese need help analysts
question their Firepower and say their
four months of mandatory military
service is poor which is by Grassroots
training groups are springing up
are both students of Kuma Academy a
private organization founded in 2021 and
recently given a donation of some 19
million euros by Taiwanese Tycoon
Robertson
the organization aims to give civil
defense training to some 3 million
people over the next three years
today under the watchful eye of his
instructory carefully raises and moves
fellow students posing as wounded
as China ramps up its rhetoric towards
the Taiwanese people their unease about
the Island's future has been growing
Shea is among them
we've been living on this island for a
long time we have our own systems in our
own Lifestyles most of us are reluctant
to see that change
but the training here is not just about
moving the wounded on a Battlefield
after attending one of the day's
lectures Ann is doing some follow-up
research on her phone about how to fight
disinformation a common tactic in war
information Warfare is real and you can
see it everywhere
I've been trying so hard to communicate
with elderly people I tell them not to
believe fake news or what's illogical
you'll feel frustrated because you don't
have time to teach them how to
distinguish the two
English
one of the co-founders of Kuma Academy
says the classes aim to foster a sense
of hope among Taiwanese people and show
people how they can play a part in the
National Defense
took office in 2013 the rising threats
posed by China to Taiwan became a
reality
and the example of the Ukraine war has
shown the Taiwanese people that the risk
of War over Taiwan is very possible
also knows that any possible aggression
from mainland China doesn't necessarily
start with a bullet
another reason why he finds Kuma's
training so important
many people are unaware that war might
begin in different forms for example
cyber attacks or trade Wars China wants
to destroy our will to resist and
they've been doing this for a while
civilians in their own ways are
strengthening civil defense
no one wants a war over Taiwan but Shea
believes in preparing for the worst
Jeff Kingston is director of Asian
studies at Temple University Japan
a Grassroots organization giving crash
courses to Taiwanese citizens on civil
defense what does that tell you about
taiwan's preparedness
well tells me that they're learning the
lessons of Ukraine and also underscores
the huge military gap between China and
Taiwan China has a million soldiers
Taiwan has 88 000. so after two decades
of double-digit increases military
spending on China side Taiwan this year
has a record increase of 15 percent but
overall its defense budget remains
around 20 billion dollars one-tenth of
what China's is
so is the government really doing enough
because analysts have described
mandatory service in Taiwan which is
only a few months as poor
and they're right uh when they ended
conscription 2018 uh that was a big
Turning Point uh the short training
period that people undergo uh they don't
actually handle weapons it's more
conceptual so yes I agree with those
analysts who believe that that is
insufficient and that's why I think the
chip Tycoon has stepped in say look we
need territorial defense we also need to
train snipers all this in service of
porcupine National defense strategy
which is to make it too costly for China
to invade
but as far as conventional Warfare
practices go where does Taiwan stand do
you think Taiwan does stand a chance
against a giant like China
well uh that's why I think that it
behooves them to adopt asymmetrical
systems like Stinger missiles and mobile
artillery uh type of uh weapon systems
that are hard to Target and hard to
counter and the United States has been
making these available and in the new
U.S defense budget they earmarked a
little over eight billion dollars of
Grants and Loans to make this possible
it also seems the United States is going
to engage in joint military training so
I think everybody recognizes a lot more
needs to be done but I think that the
Ukraine has underscored the value of
asymmetrical defense and I think that
Taiwan will be pouring more of its
efforts in that direction
and we're all very aware of Russia's
intentions as far as Ukraine goes and
the region but what about China's
intentions China is of course holding
its Communist Party Congress this week
what has leadership Ping's speech told
us
no surprises I mean he reiterated uh
what was uh declared in the August white
paper in Taiwan that China will not
renounce the use of force and they all
take all means necessary uh to deal with
what they refer to as the Taiwan problem
but I think that she has seen what can
go wrong uh with Putin's invasion of the
Ukraine so I think it probably makes it
less likely that he will invade
and any concerns from where you are
Japan uh being the second biggest
economy in Asia and important
instability for the region
well clearly uh Japan sees a threat to
Taiwan as a threat to Japan uh last year
um uh Shinzo Abe basically sent a very
clear warning to China that a military
attack on Taiwan would lead to a
Japanese military response and that's
the first time in the post-war period
that Japan has ever made such a threat
uh the current uh kishida government has
sort of tried to backpedal away from
that I think that they want to emphasize
more on uh diplomacy but clearly they
have a lot at stake and they are
committed to the defense of Taiwan but
you know as your report indicates Taiwan
is very vulnerable to cyber attacks and
also trade embargas and so these are
vulnerabilities uh that China May
exploit short of an invasion
Jeff Kingston director of Asian studies
at Temple University Japan thank you
very much for your analysis